البشر مرتبطون بانهم مخلوقات اجتماعيه
ولكن لا يزال هناك الكثير مما لا نفهمه
حول كيفيه تغيير ادمغتنا عندما نكون في
شراكه مع احد دراسه حديثه من جامعه كيوف
في اليابان اظهرت انه عندما يعمل شخصان او
اكثر معا في المهمه نفسها او نفسها فان
المنطقه الرئيسيه في ادمغه العاملين في
فريق واحد تصبح متناغمه اذا جازته هذه
نتائج تشير الى انه يمكن مطابقه النشاط
العصبي لبعضنا البعض عندما نكون في
مجموعات وبحسب دراسه عندما تعاون لاكمال
المهمه فكانت النتيجه كما لو كانت ديما
غانعمان معا كنظام واحد لحل المشكلات بشكل
ابداعي اقوى ربما وبحسب ما جاء في الدراسه
فان الادمغه تكون في وضع من التواصل عندما
يتحاور شخصان يعملان معا
[موسيقى]
من القاهره تنضم الينا مدربه تصوير مهارات
فاتن سلامه اهلا بك يا فاتن معنا في
الصباح العربيه هل بالفعل يؤثر العمل
الجماعي على الدماغ وعلى القدرات
الابداعيه
صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير نادين واتفق
او اختلف مع رايكم على صلاح وازاي التيم
يؤثر عليه
في اليابان
نادين جاي يهدي النفوس بينك انت ورشا على
فكره هي هذا الباب وراء الكواليس يعني مش
عايزه اقول لكم حصل ايه وراء الكواليس
[ضحك]
الذاتيه بتاعتنا او الملفات الشخصيه
وخصوصا على المواقع الاحترافيه مثل لينك
لما بنيجي ندي قدوس لحد او بنعطي استحقاق
دائما ما بنشير الى ان الشخص ده تيم بلاير
هذه الدراسه والتي اجريت في اليابان ليست
بجديده خليني ارجع لسنه 1970 عندما قام
جيري تشرد
وهو شخص مهتم بالاورجنيزيشن او السلوك
المؤسسي وشاف انه الاهم من ان التيم ورك
بيعمل هارموني او انسجام ما بين اعضاء
الفريق لقى ان هو بيؤثر على قدرتهم
الابداعيه لو توفرت ثلاث شروط في الشركه
اول حاجه يكون بتاع الشركه او المؤسسه
واضح لكل اعضاء الفريق الاتجاه الشركه
ايضا يكون واضح وكمان السبورت او الدعم
اذا حدث بنسميه هيلث كونفليكت او اختلاف
ما بين اعضاء الفريق واللي دايما ما يحدث
وكانه مرات يعني فاتن نحن نميل عن قصد او
عين غير قصد على فكره العمل الفردي يعني
حتى مثلا كنت الاحظ اطفال عم بيلعبوا
فوتبول مع بعض ما في فكره العمل الجماعي
كل طفل همه انه تضل الطابه معه بدون ما
يشارك بالباسيز مع الاخرين فما بعرف اذا
هذا الموضوع هو عن قص او عن غير قصد يكبر
معنا فكره انه لا نعرف ان نعمل بشكل جماعي
هو للاسف انتشار التكنولوجيا بصوره كبيره
جدا او الاسكيل بتاعه ان انا شخص عندي
مهارات تكنولوجيه عاليه بيخلي الاشخاص
انها تنميل اكثر انها تكون انترفرت او
بتميل اكثر الى الوحده ولكن على حسب
الاحصائيات 8 من كل عشر اشخاص لابد وان
تعمل في جماعه يعني حتى لو انا شخص بيعمل
في مؤسسه فرديه مثلا انا كمثال قائمه على
التدريب لازم يكون في اشخاص بهايم داسين
لازم يكون في حد بيعمل لي سبورت لان فكره
التيم ورك هو ان ان اني اتخلى عن مهاراتي
الفرديه وارائي الفرديه وان انا احطها او
ان انا احطها لتحقيق هدف انجاز هدف في
جماعه معينه ولكن رجوعا لسؤالك يا نادين
اتخيل انه بيحدث هذا نتيجه لان في مش هقول
سلبيه العمل الجماعي ولكن سوء اداره الفرد
يعني انا كام انا اللي بدير الفرد ده فلو
هو الفرد ده مثلا بيمارس هوايه كره القدم
ولكن هو بيلعب لوحده فبالتالي انا سوقت
اضاءه يعني كان في سوق في الاداره وانا ما
فهمتوش ان انت لما تلعب مع شخص تاني يبقى
في منافسه ايجابيه ما بينكم وهتزدادوا
بتاعك او مرونتك او صلابتك في كلامك انه
هناك اهميه كبيره للتفاعلات الاجتماعيه
لغه العيون التواصل اللفظي وحده تعابير
الوجه
كلنا يعني لمسنا قد ايه هي حاجه مهمه جدا
وقت الكوفيد وقت الكوفيد لما كلنا كنا
بنعمل كل حاجه كلنا كنا حاسين قد ايه
الاحتكاك والكلامس وموضوع ان احنا نكون
بنعيش في تيم ورك حتى لو احنا بنشتغل مثلا
هايبرد اللي هو نظام نصه اون لاين ونص اوف
لاين ولكن الشركات حتى المالتي ناشونالز
اكدت على ان احنا لازم نلتقي فيه لحاجه
اسمها الاي سي اللى هو بحدد ان الشركه دي
لها ايه الاكسبكتيشن بتاعتها او توقعاتها
السي هي الكومنتيشن ازاي ان احنا بنتكلم
مع بعض وده مهم قوي ولازم يكون التواصل
فعال ما بين اعضاء التيم ده والايه اللي
هي لو بيحصل اكسكيوشن لو انا بعمل المهمه
او بعمل الخطه اذا حدث شيئا ما بعمل ايه
طيب فاتن واحنا عم نتناقش حول هذا الموضوع
كمان زميلتنا منتجه البرنامج اشواق اشارت
الى نقطه انه يعني هي بتفضل شخصين
بيشتغلوا مع بعض هل هذا يندرج ضمن التيم
ورك ولا مختلف موضوع مساله تانيه
التيم بيبدا من اثنين الى ما فوق ولكن
زياده عن السته بتزداد السلبيات بتاعته
يعني المفروض من اثنين لسته هو ده
التيمورك الفعال
كنا اتكلمنا عنها قبل كده في لقاء سابق
بنعمل منها حاجه اسمها لو انا ونادين
بنشتغل مع بعض بيكون فكره ان انا اتعلم من
نادين بتكون
الاحتماليه بتاعتها اعلى لان انا ونادين
شغالين مع بعض مركزين جدا مع بعض غير لو
انا مثلا في فريق اكبر قد تتشتت انتباهي
قد يعني اتقاعس عن اداء مهامي لان مثلا
سهام هتشتغل او نادين هتشيل الشغل ده
كلما قل او داون سايز عدد الجروب وتحديد
المهام طبقا للسكيلز يعني المهم ما ينفعش
احنا الثلاثه ناخذ نفس المهام لان السكيلز
بتاعتنا مختلفه لان ممكن تكون سهام بتبص
للصوره ونادين بتهتم بالتفاصيل فبالتالي
احدد وافراد بطريقه على حسب مهاره الف
درسته ههه شكرا لك
مش انت عشان هلا قالت انه سهام تدرس
الصوره الكبيره وانا التفاصيل بما انه على
التفاصيل
والله
الانسان بطبعه يميل الى الانانيه
ولا يعطي العمل الفردي مثلا تقديرا خاصا
للشخص اكثر من العمل الجماعي وبالتالي هيك
بينشط دماغه كمان
مهم قوي قبل ما ادخل اشتغل في اي مؤسسه
اعمل اللي احنا بنسميه سايكو ماتريكتيست
ليا انا وليكي انت كشخص بيشتغل معي عشان
افهم الفرق ما بين شخصيتي وشخصيتك وهما
كتير في الدسك فيل انيا جرام فهمي لفرق ما
بين شخصيتي وشخصيتك لو انا شخص مثلا بيحب
الاستحقاق او بيحب التميز فبالتالي انا في
بيئه عمل فيها تيم ورك اكتر هتكون مصدر
قلق يعني زي المصدر قلق انا عايز اخذ كل
الكريدت لنفسي عايز اكذب كل النجاحات
لنفسي ولكن لو انا عارف ان انا مثلا شخصيه
بتعمل تحت ضغط انا مثلا شخصيه يعني استطيع
تعديد المهام ولكن شخص اخر مش هقول نادين
ولا سامع عشان ما تزعلوش شخص اخر بيحب ان
هو يعمل مهمه في وقت واحد يعني
احنا كفريق احنا كفريق متكامل ولكن ربوعا
لسؤالك يا نادين هو على حسب الشخص يعني في
اشخاص بتبدع وتتالق في العمل مثلا الناس
اللي بتشتغل في مايكروسوفت اللي هو
السيستم انجنيرز او بيشتغلوا مثلا في حاجه
لها علاقه بالارت لها حاجه لها علاقه
بالفنون الاشخاص دي لا تستطيع انها تعمل
في جماعه ولكن عشان تكتمل المنظومه
بتاعتها هتحتاج اشخاص اخرى مش هيعملوا
الشغل ولكن توصاصتين او اكسكيوت البيزنس
موديل بتاعهم هتحتاج اشخاص اخرى معاهم
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر الحديث دائما تتمه
من القاهره مدرب التطوير مهارات فاتن سلام